you have to
buckle up
you need to commit yourself
to working hard
not just hard but twice as hard
it's walking through an experience
with the people
who really
are misguided they're misinformed
about who you are
and so they're fitting you in
in their terms
i went to university to learn how to
become a better actor and to last longer
in the business because i was well aware
of indigenous actors at that time you
know playing leathers and feathers
when i was growing up there weren't any
role models out there except for maybe
harry smith from six nations
why can't i be the king of england why
can't i be the king of france you know
why don't people see me that way
i was one of the generation that kind of
plowed the road for these young kids who
said if he can do it then we can do it
too and now native people are coming out
of the woodwork they're writing their
own scripts producing their own films
getting on television networks
the industry should continue down the
path that it's on one step after another
is
stay on the path
that is
paved
with compassion
with empathy
with faith
with love
anywhere we walk
is the opportunity
to
be a piece of truth
i encourage young indigenous artists to
keep asking questions learn from the
best and learn from the up and coming
know who you are
i think that's the great challenge in
life
keep your head on straight and
keep your head above what's going on
don't get immersed into
the quagmire of misery and suffering and
the poisons that lurk around
just stay away from that stuff
be your own person and be steadfast
if you build your audience that's what
will attract business they don't really
care how cute your song is i'm sorry to
say but the people really pulling the
strings want to know whether it's going
to sell and bring in money to support
their company an ally
is not a leader
so when you're ally you're side by side
that's a little tendency that we have to
put up with in terms of people from
outside of our culture feeling that oh
well i'm better educated or i'm smarter
i know that answer and i'm pushing
forward
and
we don't really need that we have to
acknowledge the truth
and the great spiritual path to healing
can often include pain
but we have to acknowledge the truth
before we rush to reconciliation
the best thing to do is to educate
yourself there's so much information
available at your fingertips on the
internet do yourself a favor go seek it
out because you will learn more by
asking your own questions don't rely on
getting answers from the first
indigenous person you see because you
know we get asked so much it's
exhausting and it's also very personal
because we're going through trauma we
don't want
sympathy we want understanding
we want
to understand what what had happened
and what has happened and what still is
going on deny the narrative that this
was some isolated incident
[Music]
now
channel your feelings of anger toward
action
uncover undocumented graves across
canada's residential schools
get it done
there has to be tremendous work done on
the part of settler culture to come
towards us
and that is an act of reconciliation